VIC IGLESIAS: So over
the course of the day,
you've seen a lot of
technologies presented and ways
in which you can optimize
for operators and developers
and things like that.
What we want to do
in this session is
show you something you
could build end-to-end
with these technologies
and how you would use them,
kind of give you the
use case for how these
might be stitched together.
So my name is Vic Iglesias.
I'm a Cloud Solutions Architect.
The other two are
Ameer and Steve.
And they are the
brave folks who are
going to do the live
demo portion of what
I'll be explaining.
So I get the easy part here
and they're the real heroes.
So I'll first talk about why
you should build a platform.
Then we'll talk
about the platform
that we're demoing today
and what that looks like.
Ameer will demo the
onboarding of an application
to the platform.
And then Steve will talk about
how we roll out to production.
So why should you
build a platform?
We'll start this
conversation by talking
about what is a platform?
And really, it's this
idea of an abstraction
between your developers
and operators.
It's the simplest
way I can put it.
You want your developers
to have one single way
that they know how to
iterate on their services,
and that they're
really good at it.
But also, as operators,
you want to be
able to iterate on the
underlying infrastructure.
You don't want to be
stuck on whatever decision
you made five years
ago for infrastructure.
You want to be able to
iterate on those pieces
while maintaining your
developers' productivity.
That's a huge, huge task.
So what we do is
we build platforms.
We build these
abstractions that allow
developers to do their
things and stay consistent.
You might have 100
times more developers
than you do operators.
So you want to make sure
that those folks are
able to iterate.
And how many folks
in here actually,
like, their company
ships software
and then makes money from it?
Yeah.
A lot of us, right?
You have to do that.
How many folks have to have
software to run your business?
The rest of them, right?
We need to maintain the
developer productivity
and keep high reliability as we
work through these challenges.
When you look under
the covers, things
get pretty complicated
a lot of the time.
You started in your data center.
Things were fine.
You maybe had just dev and prod.
People were just
SSH-ing to machines
and throwing JARs everywhere
from the very beginning.
That got a little cagey.
So you added a staging
logical environment,
so you could test
out your changes.
Then from there, you
added a cloud provider.
Maybe it was GCP, who knows?
And you started to
complicate things,
now having two physical
locations where
things are located also
having those many logical
environments.
So things get complex under
the hood for these operators.
And we want to make that easier.
Some of the complications
you end up with here
are inconsistent ways that
people deploy, or think
about CI, or run their builds.
And all of that stuff means that
you aren't sharing your best
practices with each other.
All of the innovation
that you're
seeing in one part
of your company
is not being leveraged
in the others.
Another thing that
you start to see
is that those logical
environments don't actually
mean what you
thought they meant.
You thought you had a
staging environment that was
staged to be, like, production.
But at the end of the
day, it's so far from it
that you're not
even learning things
that would hit production,
and you're seeing
your bugs hit prod anyway.
Obviously, you can't
test for everything,
but that's the goal of having
those logical environments.
The next thing is you
start figuring out
that it's hard to
even get people
the right access
to the right things
to be able to get
their job done.
You want a standard way to
do those kinds of things,
including configuring which
apps can connect to each other.
Dan showed a great demo of
Istio on the service mesh,
and things that we can actually
use to connect services
in a secure and reliable way.
The last one is mostly
for operators here,
where each team does
ops differently.
And so when an
outage hits, you have
to figure out what their
best practices for logging
and monitoring and
all that stuff are,
and where their systems are, and
how they do their actual logs,
and whether they're JSON or not.
You start to see a
lot of this stuff
when you're not
building platforms
to operate-- for
developers and operators
to have an abstraction.
So then you say, Vic,
we've had platforms.
We've had things like
App Engine, things
like Cloud Foundry,
hosted platforms,
platforms as a service.
In 2008, Google
launched App Engine.
And this helped a
lot of companies
not think about all the
operational aspects.
They just got to
scale to millions
of requests per second for free
with just a little bit of code.
Turns out, this seemed very
opinionated to enterprises.
It was too hard for them to
make a leap into the platform
as a service world.
So we started to see
platforms, like infrastructure
as a service, like
Compute Engine in 2012,
which was launched, which
gave you the most flexibility.
You just run a VM and
put software on it.
It's going to be easy.
Turns out, that was
kind of hard as well.
In 2015, we launched
Kubernetes Engine.
And that was kind of a
happy medium for folks.
It was enough of an
infrastructure abstraction.
It turns out, it can run
kind of anywhere now.
And this is now a
new building block
that folks are building their
kind of bespoke platforms
on top of.
And what you get here is a
nice infrastructure abstraction
and then the ability
to add all the pieces
that you need in between.
And there may be some bespoke
choices in your company,
like you chose a particular
identity provider or a secrets
management tool that
you need to integrate,
and Kubernetes gives you
a lot of the flexibility
to make those choices.
How many folks know this
gentleman, Kelsey Hightower?
He's awesome.
We pray to him for
Ameer and Steve's sake
that the demo goes well.
Kelsey said that
"Kubernetes is a platform
for building platforms."
It's not your endgame.
It's a better place to start.
And that's kind of
what we're going
to do throughout this
talk and the demo.
So how do you build
a platform on Anthos?
First thing to look
at is, what are
the layers of your
stack when you're
talking about applications?
You have infrastructure
layers, which
is your networking,
your compute, storage,
things like that.
Anthos provides a way
to abstract that away.
And so above that, you create
kind of platform tools or sets
of tools that make
up your platform.
You might have a source code
management system, a CI system,
and a continuous delivery system
that you build on top in order
to give your developers that
git commit to do the right thing
experience.
So why would you build
on top of Anthos?
You get a central--
centrally manage
your infrastructure.
We had Anthos Config Management
as an example of that.
You get a single API
that you know you
can use to deploy workloads.
You have an interface, which
is like the Docker image.
And then you know
from there, you
can go to any of your locations
or environments and deploy.
And it allows you to then
share those methodologies
across your teams, or
centralize those methodologies,
and then extend them.
And as I said previously, you
can run Kubernetes and GKE
now anywhere, whether it
be on-prem or in the cloud.
So as we're building
our platforms,
we're thinking about
three main personas--
the developers, the
security and policy folks,
who are trying to
figure out what
can't be done in the
platform, and our operators,
who are just trying to keep
the lights on and make sure
that things are
running smoothly.
In order build a
platform, we think
you need to have one of
each of these components.
I talked about a lot of these.
Dan talked about
app observability,
which we can introduce with
Istio and Anthos Service Mesh.
We need a way to
manage our source code,
a way to manage
our configuration,
CI/CD methodologies, a
way to manage our policy,
and then ways to
run our containers.
So in this talk,
in the demo, we'll
go through what it's
like to build this out,
choosing one of each
of these components,
and then stitching
it all together
and showing it to you folks.
As we've gone
through this, we've
seen that there's
really three interfaces
that these components use
to talk to each other.
We have Git repositories,
so we can push and pull
code, source code.
Sometimes that's a
Kubernetes manifest.
We can push and pull Docker
images from a repository.
That's our deployable artifact.
And then we configure
that deployable artifact
using Kubernetes manifest
that we deploy to clusters.
The way that we're using
Anthos Configuration Management
in this example is by
using it to sync policy
and structure of namespaces
across our clusters.
So we store all of
that configuration
in a centralized Git
repo, and then it
gets applied to all
of our clusters.
And what we end up with in
each of these namespaces
that we create for
applications is one service
account that that
application uses
to deploy within that cluster.
It has a CI runner.
So in our case,
we're using GitLab,
so we have a GitLab CI runner
running in that namespace
just for that application.
And then that deploys
with that service
account all the resources
that the application requires,
whether that's deployments
or services or ingresses
or anything like that.
And then these
are all replicated
across each of our clusters.
So as we add a cluster
to an environment,
it gets the same exact
setup as the other clusters
that's in there.
It's a nice way to
centralize that.
The other thing we're
going to be doing
is deployment with GitOps.
So this has been an idea
that's been around for a while
and now has a name to it--
the GitOps methodology.
And what that means
is we're going
to have our application
configuration living inside
of an app repo, and we're
going to have our Kubernetes
config in there, and then we're
going to hydrate that manifest.
We're going to render that
manifest into a fully-fledged
Kubernetes manifest that can
be applied into a cluster.
But before doing that,
we're going to commit it
to a Git repository.
And that gives us a way to
track what was deployed and when
and what the diffs were
between those commits.
So in this example,
we're going to have
that environment repo have
two branches, one staging
branch, which maps to what's
in the staging clusters,
and then one master branch,
which maps to what's
in production.
As far as managing our
configuration, our application
configuration, we're
going to be using
Kustomize, which
is a way to manage
your Kubernetes manifest.
Rather than templating
them, you're
going to be able to create
a base set of manifests,
and then apply patches to
them for various use cases.
Another thing that
Kustomize can do
is apply labels and annotations
across a set of resources
and/or add a prefix.
So a big use case
for adding a prefix
is I want to prefix everything
with the environment name.
So you have a base
that just says
what your resources are,
and then in Kustomize,
you can apply prod
dash or staging
dash to all the resources.
So when you see them
in your dashboards
and in your Kubernetes
CLI, you can
tell which environment
you're in really easily
without having to go into
each of those resources
and change it yourself.
And one of the key methodologies
that Kustomize uses
is to have these patches
on top of a base.
The other place that we see
this is in Docker images.
You have in Docker, from
Ubuntu 16.04 or 18.04,
that's the base image.
Then you run commands
on top of that
and make little tweaks
to the filesystem.
We have a very similar
approach with Kustomize.
So you have a set
of base manifests.
And then from there, you
add overlays or patches
on top of that that
sprinkle in the changes
that you want without
changing that original base.
That base might be used for
a completely different use
case in another
place, and you just
do what you need in order
to transform that for yours.
One concrete way you
could see this is I
have a base set of
Kubernetes manifests
that I call my application.
And then for each
of my environments,
I have environment-specific
patches
that I apply to each of
those before I finally
hydrate those and submit
them into my clusters.
That's a very basic
use case for Kustomize.
So now on the demo, we'll
talk through a little bit
of the cloud architecture.
We'll have five
clusters in this demo.
We'll have one for dev.
That is where they can iterate.
They have some
namespaces that they're
locked into in that cluster.
They iterate with something
like Skaffold or Cloud Run
on their own, and then
they commit some code.
Oops.
We need the slides back and
power up here, it looks like.
So you have a tools
cluster in there.
We have our CI/CD tools.
All those platform pieces
that I talked about
in that layered
infrastructure diagram
are going to be in
the tools cluster.
We're using GitLab for this.
And so the developers are going
to commit and merge in GitLab,
and then that's going to
make its way to staging,
and then finally, to
production clusters.
Here we have one staging cluster
and two production clusters.
And I'll talk a little bit
about how the code repos work.
Again, we're going to have
two main repos-- the code repo
and the environment repo.
When a developer commits
to a feature branch,
they're iterating on
their local environment.
Then eventually, they're
going to make a merge request
to the master branch
of the CI repo.
Then from there,
that's automatically
going to be committed to the
staging repo of-- or the, yeah,
staging branch of
the environment repo
and added to the
staging environment.
So now everything that's in
master of the developer's repo
is ready to go in staging.
Now, if we want to get a change
from staging to production,
we merge in the environment
repo from staging to master,
and that does a CI run or a
CD run that pushes directly
into the production clusters.
So with that, we'll
kick it over to Ameer,
who will take us through it.
AMEER ABBAS: Sounds good.
Can you guys hear me?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AMEER ABBAS: All right.
Everybody clear on
what Vic just said?
VIC IGLESIAS: Ha.
AMEER ABBAS: Do we
need to run this demo?
We're running on, like, 7%--
we're running on,
like, 6% battery life.
So I'm going to go pretty fast.
All right, so--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, we just found out
that it's not charging.
So my name is Ameer.
I'm also an SA, Solutions
Architect, here at Google.
And I will be your operator
for the rest of the 10 minutes
or so that we have.
Let's all put on
our operators hats.
And let's assume that our
developer just walked up to us
and said, hey, I have this
new Go app I'd like to deploy.
Hi, Myles, How are you?
MYLES: [INAUDIBLE].
AMEER ABBAS: Awesome.
And then so what do we do?
So like any other
platform as a service,
we'd start with the CLI,
which is what you see up here.
We have this
handy-dandy CLI tool
that we are going to use to
add a new application called
hello-kubecon-1 into
our CI/CD platform.
Maybe.
All right, let me just make
sure I'm in the right folder.
Huh?
Log out.
Is that good?
No, one more.
One more.
All right.
CLI is a good way of
adding an application.
It's nice and consistent.
Everybody gets
treated the same way.
You don't make any
kind of human mistakes.
But in this
particular case, we're
using anthos-platform-cli.
The name of our
application is just
going to be hello-kubecon-2019.
We give it our CI/CD's
hostname, which in this case
is GitLab, the password,
and then the template.
So again, template gives you
kind of that boilerplate code
kind of already made up.
So what's happening
in the background,
I'll just quickly explain, is in
GitLab, it's creating a group.
And a group is nothing
more than just a collection
of repositories, just like
an organization on GitHub.
And in this case, it's creating
those two repositories.
One is your application
code repositories.
That's what you hand
off to your developers.
That's where they iterate
on their applications.
And then the other one is
your operator's repository
or your environment
repositories.
That's where all of
the Kubernetes resource
manifests reside for all
environments, so for dev,
stage, and prod.
Keeping those two
separate kind of
keeps the CI of the
developer separated
from the CD of the operator.
It's a nice way to do that.
Another thing that
Vic mentioned is
that every application gets
deployed in its own namespace
on every single cluster.
And as part of that
namespace, a GitLab runner,
which is just a deployment,
is deployed inside
of that namespace.
Now, there's a couple of
schools of thought here.
One is, how do we push these
manifests down to the clusters?
So there's two ways to do that.
We can either give kind of the
credentials to the Git repos,
and every single Git repo
for every single Kubernetes
cluster, and we push
those configs down,
so the credentials
kind of remain
outside of it, or in this case,
we are giving those credentials
as a service account
to the GitLab runner,
and then giving the GitLab
runner the Git credentials,
so it can pull those manifests.
In order to do that, we have
to give this GitLab runner
access to pull those images.
So I'm going to
click on this link
and I'm just going to
create some credentials.
So this is very similar to
just creating a Docker login.
And in this case, the
only thing it really needs
is read access to the registry,
so it can pull the images.
So I'll create a user
called git-reader.
It doesn't matter
what we call it.
We'll give it
read_registry access.
I'll create the deploy
token, and it'll give me
this username and password.
We'll copy this password,
go back to our command line,
give it the username, which is
git-reader, copy the password,
and let it kind of
finish the bootstrap.
So let's take a look at what
actually got created in GitLab.
So I'm going to go into
GitLab, go to Groups,
and go to Your groups, so
we can see all of them.
So the first thing
you notice is that we
have this new group created
called hello-kubecon-2019.
If we go into that group, we
have the two repositories.
The bottom one is your
application repository.
That's the one for
your developers.
The top one is your env, or
your environment repository.
That's the one for your resource
manifests for Kubernetes.
We'll inspect
those here shortly.
I'm going to go back
into the groups,
and I'm going to look at this
group called platform-admins.
And this is an operator's group.
There's quite a few
repositories kind of in here.
So I'll highlight a few of them.
The first one are these
templated repositories,
so the golang-template and
the golang-template-env.
Again, like I said, it kind
of gives our developers
a starting point of
something they can code,
so you don't have to do
this every single time.
So you can have other
templates for Java, Ruby, Go,
and what have you.
We heard about Anthos Config
Management this morning.
And this is the
platform that sets up
kind of the foundation, the
namespaces, the registries,
and stuff like that.
Inside of this repository--
this is, by the way,
what the folder structure
looks like-- there's
a namespaces folder.
So we go into the
namespaces folder
and the managed-apps folder.
You can see that we now have--
as part of that bootstrap
that we did with
the CLI command,
we have a
hello-kubecon-2019 folder.
We'll go into that folder.
And you'll notice
that, like I said,
it creates the namespace
for that application.
It creates that registry secret.
That's that Docker login
that we just created.
And it feeds that to all
of the GitLab runners
in each namespace
for each cluster.
So you see the three runners,
two for the production
clusters-- prod-central,
prod-east-- and the staging.
So now each cluster
has pull permissions
to pull images
from that registry.
And if we want to look
at what that looks
like inside of the cluster--
so again, I'm in
the Cloud Console.
We're looking at the Kubernetes
Engine Workloads page.
And I've already put a filter
for that namespace on there.
And if we hit Refresh,
you'll notice that we
have the three GitLab runners.
We also have something
else deployed.
And we'll talk
about that shortly.
But I really wanted you to
focus on the three runners that
are scoped to that
namespace-- so they're
running within that
hello-kubecon-2019 namespace--
in each of the clusters--
the two production clusters
and the one staging cluster.
And their permissions are
scoped within that namespace.
They can't put anything
outside of that.
So let's go back to our
platform-admins group.
Another thing I
wanted to show you
was the shared CI/CD repository.
So this is where all of the
CI/CD for every single language
will sit here.
So in the CI
folder, for example,
you'll have all of the manifests
for different CI files.
So we have one for Go
here as an example.
And you can see,
it's fairly simple.
It's doing a unit test,
which just go get, go test,
and then just a build stage.
Again, this could be as
deep as you'd like it to be.
And then the last thing
I want to mention here
are Kustomize bases.
These are the shared
Kustomize bases,
like Vic talked about,
for every language.
We have a folder.
So we can go into
the golang folder.
And in this demo,
we're just doing
a deployment and a service.
But you can have other
Kubernetes manifests,
and they don't
look scary at all.
They look just like a vanilla
Kubernetes deployment.
And things, like we can
change our environment,
so which environment
they're going into-- dev,
stage, or prod.
We can change the image
name, because the majority
of the time, you're not
changing the entire YAML.
You're just changing
a few things.
And that's where that
patch kind of comes in.
And to show you that, now
let's go ahead and inspect
our actual application group.
So I'm going to go back into
hello-kubecon-2019 group,
and we're going to start
with the application repo.
So again, this is
the boilerplate.
This is the repository that gets
handed over to the developers.
And you can see,
the first thing,
we just gave them
some boilerplate code.
This is just a simple
Hello World! app
that the developers can
start iterating upon.
In the same repositories,
we have the Dockerfile,
so this is what
builds the artifacts.
We have Skaffold, so they can
start doing some developments
and local dev testing
before they even push this
to this particular repo.
We have this gitlab-ci,
which is their CI/CD file
for this particular repo.
This pipeline gets kicked
off anytime somebody commits,
makes a commit to the master
branch of this application
repo.
And I already showed
you the test and build.
And Steve's going to show you
how the deployment piece works.
What's interesting about this
is, as part of the application
repo, we also have the
Kubernetes manifest.
So the developers
not only get to see
what actually gets
deployed, they also
have influence over
how it does it.
So inside of that k8s folder,
we have the three folders
for the three environments.
So for example, if we go
to the staging folder,
first thing is that
it's pulling that shared
Kustomize bases from that repo
that I showed you earlier.
So as an operator, I
can go and make a change
to that shared base one time.
If, let's say, I want to
change the logging level,
or if I want to add resource
limits, or something,
I'll just change it one time,
and in the next rollout,
this will get applied
across the board.
And then here's the patch,
the deployment patch
that is being applied for
this particular thing.
And if we just
look at that very,
very quickly, all
we're doing here
is giving it the
ENVIRONMENT variable
and then giving it the
name of the image, which
Steve will show you shortly.
So as a developer, I
can actually go in,
and I can change
this patch to-- let's
say if I want more
CPU or something,
or if I want to
change the image,
if I want to push a
different image to staging,
I can do that here.
So I still have that
control over staging.
So now I mentioned that
every time a commit
is made to the master branch,
a pipeline is kicked off.
So here on the
left-hand side, I'm
going to go to CI/CD, Pipelines.
And you can see that
one pipeline because
of the initial bootstrapping
was kicked off.
And let's click
on that pipeline.
And it's just a simple
four-stage CI/CD step.
Again, this could be as
complex as you'd like.
The first two are
pretty self-explanatory.
And I already kind
of showed you those.
This is the unit
test that happened,
and then the building
of that image.
Once that image is
built in the registry,
somehow we need to deploy that.
And for that, I'm going
to hand it off to Steve,
and he's going to talk more
about how that gets deployed.
STEVE MCGHEE: Thank you, Ameer.
AMEER ABBAS: Sure.
STEVE MCGHEE:
[INAUDIBLE] all right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEVE MCGHEE: Yeah?
All right, cool.
I'm Steve McGhee.
I'm a former SRE.
So I get the honor/duty
of pushing this thing
into production.
So pray.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
STEVE MCGHEE: So the first
thing we're going to do
is it's still part
of the CI step,
but it's kind of the
beginning of CD, which
is hydrating these manifests.
So these are these YAML files
that we talked about before.
So before we had the base
image and the patches,
and you kind of think about
variables and templates.
This is all of it expanded out.
So we have two files.
One's going to be
Kustomize staging.
The other one's Kustomize prod.
And that way, if we have
any trouble down the line,
we know exactly what got
pushed to production.
The first step is
just to build those.
And we can click through here.
And we can show you,
it builds them all.
It's very simple.
It builds one right here.
It runs a Kustomize command
for Kustomize staging,
and then it does it
again for production.
So after that, we
have these two files.
What we do with them?
We just push them
over to another repo.
So now we're moving
from the code repo
to the environment repo.
I won't really show you this,
because it's just a copy.
It's not very interesting.
So let's back out
into the group.
And we're going to show you the
env repo, the environment repo.
And we'll show you where
those files kind of end up.
So I go here.
Oh, my gosh!
Where are the files?
Well, we forgot.
We actually pushed
it to a branch.
We pushed it to
the staging branch.
So as soon as we move
over there, here we go,
we've got our two files.
So we can look at one.
Let's look at staging.
And it shouldn't be
scary in any way.
It's pretty basic.
So we have our
environment label,
staging, just like we expect.
It has the name, hello-kubecon.
So all those things that
looked all vanilla before
have all been filled in
with the right stuff.
So we saw before that there
were three runners running
in Kubernetes.
And there was also
a job running.
There was the
actual staging app.
So this is this guy right here.
It already got out there.
How the heck did that happen?
And the reason why
that happened is
because when we made
the first commit,
we pushed this file all the
way to the environment branch,
into the staging branch, and
our friend, the pipeline,
ran again.
So let's see this new
pipeline that ran.
This is a different pipeline.
This one, doo-doo-doo,
just did one thing.
It deployed to staging.
So we can click in here.
We can see there's this job
that ran, this binary that runs.
We're using something
called gke-deploy.
And think of it just
as, like, kubectl apply,
except it does a couple of
other little fancy things,
and it waits for it to succeed.
And then once it
does, it sort of
tells you, here, go look at your
job, it's running, it's great.
So we can see, yes,
indeed, it's running.
So at this point, the
developer says, great.
My job is what I expected.
The feature is
doing the featuring.
Let's push it to prod.
And then the SRE shows
up, and goes, you got it.
Let's do it.
The schedule is correct.
We're ready to go.
And then, if you recall from the
kind of interesting flow chart,
the way we do this
is we're going
to do it by promoting
the environment
YAML from the staging
branch to the master branch.
We do that in
GitLab using what's
called a merge request, which
you probably already know.
We're going to make
a new merge request.
We're going to give it a
very, very descriptive name,
like, go.
Oh, no.
The computer
stopped computering.
OK.
Prod.
So we're going to go to prod.
So we want to make
sure we're actually
going from staging to master.
That looks pretty good.
We're going to submit
a merge request.
Some other person might come in.
Like, you might want to
have another set of eyes
go, yeah, this looks fine.
They might come
in and say, well,
let's take a look
at the changes,
make sure they're
exactly what we expect.
You might also have other
things in your pipeline,
like, to make sure that we have
the right amount of resources
in place, et cetera.
This is really boring, because
it's just like a blank entry.
But let's say it looks good.
We're going to merge it.
Let's go.
So now what happens
in this process?
Yet another pipeline happens.
Of course, it does.
That's how this works.
In this case, there is
one step for each cluster,
so for each production cluster.
And it's exactly the same as the
staging one, except this time,
it's pushing to production.
So we have two clusters here.
One is just in central1.
Look, it already finished.
And the next one's
going to be in east1.
You might have another
step in here that's like,
wait, or check the canary,
or something-something,
but we just did
something very simple.
So let's take a
look at Kubernetes
and make sure it's working.
It should be ready.
Ah, it's working!
So we have one
running in central1.
And then the us-east1
is coming up as well.
So
Let's take a look
at the Logs Viewer.
And we're going to see
if it is really running.
So for each cluster,
we should be
able to see the
health checks come by.
And ideally, what
we're going to see
is three sets of apps all
running kind of skewed
from each other.
Stream.
This is it, guys.
This is going to be it.
And this is where
we pray to Kelsey.
So we have health
checks in staging.
We have it in prod.
We have it in prod-central.
And eventually, we'll have
ones from prod-east as well.
But that's it.
Our code is deployed.
It's in many places.
Another thing to point out,
prod-east and prod-central
could be two different
types of Kubernetes
on two different platforms.
This is the amazing
thing about Anthos.
It doesn't care.
It's just Kubernetes.
So that's it.
[CHEERING]
[APPLAUSE]
VIC IGLESIAS: Woo!
All right.
If we could go back to
slides for a little bit.
That was pretty good.
I will continue to bring them
along for future Anthos Days.
I don't want to do the demos.
So let's take a quick review.
We saw a lot of things.
A lot of terms flew
around-- code and arrows
and all kinds of stuff.
So we had developers committing
to an application repo.
That was kicking off CI.
And then that built an
artifact, our Docker image,
and stored it in our
container registry.
From there, it was added to
our application configuration.
The operators were able to
get their base configuration,
and put that into
the application
configuration with that image.
And then that was committed
to our environment repo, where
the CD process was started.
The other thing that we saw
is that policy and security
engineers were able
to create that landing
zone for our applications
and those namespaces
with the right policies
in a Git repo as well,
and have those propagate
to all our clusters.
So that's kind of
the shape of what
a platform might look like if
it's built on top of Anthos.
The last thing I
want to just review
is a lot about how we propagated
our best practices as operators
through this platform.
With the ability to
use GitLabs includes
we can have a
centralized repo, where
we're having most
of our CI steps
that as a library that
developers can pick from.
So they have a good
starting point,
and then can iterate from there.
We also can do the same thing
for our continuous delivery
processes.
And with our
application config, we
have our shared Kustomize
bases, which we can store in Git
and then reference from
our application repos.
And so we're pulling
in our best practices.
And then as we iterate
on those as operators,
those automatically propagate on
the next run to our developers.
Also, we have the ability
to store our environment
configuration in a
repository, and have
that reviewed by
SRE and security
and whoever else
before any changes are
merged into production.
So with that, I'd ask
you to please come talk
to us at either the Google
Cloud booth or here--
I think we have a break
coming up right now--
and ask about the
Anthos platform demo.
Thank you, folks, so much.
[APPLAUSE]